all right since her decisive vote to
confirm justice Cavanaugh senator Susan
Collins of Maine has been facing fierce
backlash quote from feminists and for
not towing the political line some of
this has been beyond mean and despicable
take a look many of your opponents are
going to say she's pro-choice she is Pro
women's rights and she just sent a man
accused of sexual assault to the Supreme
Court of the United States that's
political cowardice that is somebody who
is pretending to be a feminist but that
is fake feminism I think a lot of women
in this country are going to focus very
much on Susan Collins here was a chance
for one of the most powerful women in
the country she set herself up to be the
single most powerful Senator in this
country by saying I'll tell you at three
o'clock and she came out and stood up
there as a woman and says I believe the
guy well it's got worse than that
joining us now with reaction senior
adviser to the Donald Trump for
president campaign and the president's
daughter-in-law Laura Trump is with us
Laura good to see you thank you for
being with us it seems that there's a
huge double standard you've been
attacked Ivanka has been attacked
Melania has been attacked even the
president's son who's 12 has been
attacked then you have Sarah Sanders
secretary Nielsen Pam Bondi people
getting assaulted in restaurants people
getting in their face and then what
they're saying about Susan Collins I I
don't understand how you can say you're
a champion of women's rights and allow
this to happen regularly yeah it makes
no sense Shawn actually if you want to
see a real woman if you want to see what
real feminism is about take a look at
senator Susan Collins here's a woman who
went against the mob coming after her
everyone telling her she shouldn't do
this from the left from the media from
Hollywood she went with her gut in her
heart and she made a decision on her own
despite what all these people were
telling her she should do that is what a
real woman is about to me I commend her
kudos to her she finally did the right
thing here and yes she set herself up as
the
most powerful senator by making
everybody wait until 3 o'clock this is a
very smart woman and this is the
definition of feminism in my opinion the
amount of fear-mongering though I mean I
won't get into all the details but there
have been calls
I hope the most horrific violent act
against a woman happens to you and
thousands of coat hangers sent threats
to our office threats to her I mean I'm
watching this and I'm thinking there is
a great hypocrisy because the very same
people that were going after Brett
Kavanaugh or silent about Bill Clinton
silent about keith ellison what do you
say about the double standard oh there's
a complete double standard and you know
what people are paying attention to it
and I want to tell the American people
out there if you think this is as
ridiculous as the rest of us do you have
the choice in November to vote in the
midterm elections and you better make
sure you are voting for Trump supporting
Republicans because we see how
ridiculous the Democrats can be they
know no lows this they go low we go high
nonsense I don't know where they toss
that out the window if they ever
actually believe that we have an
opportunity in November to keep the
majority and the House and Senate and it
is the most important thing that
everyone could do that voted for Donald
Trump because if you're happy with the
direction this country has gone under
Donald Trump's leadership you got to get
out and vote in the midterms otherwise
these people are going to take control
of things and we do not want to see them
or we know their agenda they're saying
it they want the the tax cuts that have
put thousands of dollars in families
pockets they want the crumbs back they
called them crumbs at the time they want
to eliminate ice they want open borders
they want to keep Obamacare and they
want to impeach your father-in-law yeah
and they're advocating for socialism
that's that's their new platform running
on socialism it is a very scary thing
and you're completely right Sean
everyone out there should understand
that if the Democrats get control of the
House and Senate they will try and
impeach this president they will
probably try to get rid of Brett
Kavanaugh on the Supreme Court they will
put a complete halt to everything good
we've seen happen in this country in the
year and a half that Donald Trump has
become a been president and everybody
should take that very very seriously you
know people tend to stay home in midterm
elections they better not this year
they better not